dabby is arguably the most mysterious
character in the world of mahir academia
what's the majority of the fandom myself
included have accepted the headcanon
that he has toyotodoroki
there's still a lot we don't know about
this character for sure like for example
where was he for all those years before
he met the league of villains and
how did toyo supposedly die like we
don't actually know this stuff
however in this video for once we're
going to be ignoring all the mystery
around this character
and instead we're going to focus on
something that is very very obvious
that being his scars and his body's lack
of durability
when it comes to using his own quirk i
have a pretty solid theory as to how
debbie will
overcome these obstacles and it came to
me a couple of weeks ago when reading
one of the latest chapters in the manga
for that reason this video will have
manga spoilers but don't let that stop
you from subscribing because
we are still on the road to 100k okay
i'm just going to get straight into it
we all know that sugar rocky recently
gained the power of all for one
which is the core of this theory because
this quote gives him the ability to both
steal quirks and transfer quirks
i realized that this provides a perfect
opportunity for the rest of the league
of villains to also be given abilities
as well
on at least two separate occasions in
the manga we've seen that dabby
seriously struggles to control the
side effects of his flames the first
time was during his battle against
getting in my villain academia
when the ice user said that he'd been
smelling dabby's burning flesh for a
while
we then see the smoke coming from
darby's scars as getting states that his
skin looks like it could peel off at any
second
it was during this battle that we got
the concrete information that we'd long
suspected
and that was that dabby cannot fight for
a long time without being consumed by
his own fire
the second time in the manga was during
the war arc and this happened when dabby
faced off
against tokyomi and hawks dabi actually
had the upper hand in this battle
because he was up against two people who
have weakness to either flames or light
but even then with the advantage he
still wasn't able to secure the win
because he kept stalling so that his
body could recover between attacks
then later on when he goes to attack
tokyo army we can literally see his skin
peeling off like it's gross and yeah
it's not not great for derby
therefore out of all sugaraki's close
allies dabi is clearly the one member
who desperately needs an additional
ability
well actually maybe spinner as well
because i mean this guy just sucks
over the years we know that dr garaki
has made several copies
of the super regeneration quirk i'm
pretty sure it would be safe to say that
i mean if we're including the black
nomus the super regeneration quirk is by
far
the quark that has had the most
different uses a power like this would
finally enable dabby to use his
cremation quirk
without any restraints as his body
should immediately heal from the damage
as a result he could begin to try out
new techniques that would normally be
too dangerous for him
such as the prominence burn or hell's
curtain i see no reason why shigaraki
wouldn't do this
as by powering up dabi in this way he
could generally go toe-to-toe with
endeavor
and i think this has to happen because
if these two you know dabi and endeavor
if they're ever gonna fight
without regeneration darby is just gonna
get flamed not just by his own fire but
also by his dads as well
also on a separate note we know that
when all for one found the regeneration
quirk many years ago
it failed to heal his pre-existing
injuries which is why he looks like this
we've also seen in the recent chapters
that shiguraki's missing fingers have
yet to grow back despite him acquiring
super regeneration
so this shows us that the quirk only
works for injuries going forward
but it doesn't heal the injuries you've
already suffered this would mean that
the power would not be enough to heal
dabi's scars if he acquired it
but there's still another quirk out
there that could do that and i'll
explain how shiguraki's fascination with
the quote destroying bullets
has been evident ever since he hijacked
a police vehicle to steal some
and then subsequently asked twice to
replicate them and then asked dr garaki
to replicate them
and then had a bunch of them mass
produced and pocketed about five more of
them after some of them were destroyed
furthermore during the overhaul arc
together found out
that eerie was the source of the bullets
and told shigeraki this over the phone
in fact she even went as far to say that
they didn't manage to kidnap her this
time
which indicates this is something that
shiguraki would obviously be open to
doing
now listen i don't want erie to go
through any more emotional trauma i
don't want it to be kidnapped or any of
this stuff
but when the king of the underworld
wants more quirk replicating bullets
and he is very much aware of the girl
whose blood is able to create them
let's just say there's a few different
ways that could go if at any point
during the series shiguraki encounters
erie
stealing her quirk or copying it that
would be quite a desirable outcome for
him for a lot of reasons not just for
the bullets but obviously he could have
a ton of other applications including
rewinding derby
i know what you're thinking though if we
rewind abby then surely that will just
turn him back into a 12 year old child
or something like that
and while that is a valid point to make
we saw during the overhaul arc itself
that with enough experimentation he was
able to turn a quirk that rewinds
people's ages
into a quirk that rewinds people's
quirks out of existence that's why when
muriel lost his quirk
instead of rewinding him to the age of 3
years old which is probably the last
time he didn't have a quirk
instead it just totally erased his quirk
whilst keeping him
the same age that right there is the
evidence that with enough
experimentation
rewind can be applied in ways that don't
de-age people
but still significantly alter them in
some way if dr graki or shigaraki are
given sufficient time
believe me i'm pretty sure they could
find a way to revert dabi into his
handsome squidward form
although saying that i'm not sure how
much of a priority is to give darby a
makeover
but yeah i'm just throwing the idea out
there now going back to the super
regeneration quirk for a second
an interesting question to ask is
whether or not shigaraki would be
willing to give dabi
his own super generation quirk and the
answer is probably
no because it's a super useful quirk for
anyone to have so shigaraki is likely
going to keep on to his version of it
that said though because shigaraki has
an army of black nomu
at his beckon call like they will
literally only act on his command
and so it's clear that he could simply
order one of them to his location
and do a quick quirk transfer to derby
we saw afo do something similar like
this in the manga
only in that case it was a quirk swap
but you know by passing the regeneration
quirk
immediately to derby from a nomu that's
there's not really any downsides to
doing that because you still have a
whole army with super
generation so at the end of the day all
you would do is take the quark from one
nomu
and give it to one of your you know
leading commanders and that my friends
is the likely way
that i think dabi will gain super
generation and i think it might happen
sooner than we think
as of the last chapter debbie was on his
way to see shigaraki with
obviously the rest of the league of
villains and once they arrived there
shiggy will be
very happy to see them and might do them
a quick favor and give him a few quirks
who knows
anyway people those are my thoughts on
how darby could gain a regeneration
quirk
and therefore defeat endeavour when they
eventually come face to face
let me know in the comments if you'd
like to see him without the scars or if
you just prefer him you know the way he
is the iconic
design of him will the scars uh should
it be taken away or should it be kept
let me know down below
also remember to submit any questions
for the patreon q a
as i will be recording that later this
week and putting it out on the weekend
so yeah be sure to get your questions in
if you have any
peace out